[Music]
welcome back this morning we continue
our coverage of fertility as more women
of color turn to sperm banks in the wake
of this pandemic they face a nationwide
shortage of donors who may share their
background CBS News analyzed the numbers
at four major U.S cryo Banks where the
sperm is donated we found that 53
percent of available sperm is from White
donors while listen to this number less
than four percent is from black donors
our new CBS News correspondent that
Chanel call is here with more Chanel
good morning to you and welcome welcome
to the table thanks for the warm welcome
this is a really important story and
unfortunately it's a heartbreaking
reality for so many women across the
country who just want to have a child
that reflects their own race and culture
the lack of options forces many of them
to choose between having a child that
doesn't look like them or not having a
baby at all
Galloway grew up in a family that
celebrated being black enjoying soul
food and having our slang and having our
words that we you know say that's like
just very very black when you started
this whole process
what did you imagine your child would
look like me like exactly like me I
already thought they were gonna just be
the mirror image of a young Jamila and
that included being 100 black now at 40
and single Galloway is using a sperm
donor to get pregnant but when she
filtered the search for donors of her
own race the number of options went from
hundreds to a handful it literally felt
like you were on a hunt it almost felt
like I was having a bit of my decision
taken away from me Dr Tia Jackson Bay a
New York City fertility doctor says
every patient of color at her practice
has shared that struggle I thought
people were exaggerating and it turned
out that that's just not true when you
filter by things like race or geographic
location or language country of origin
the numbers go from thousands down to
less than a hundred according to our
analysis of the kind country's four
largest cryobanks less than four percent
of available sperm is black why are we
seeing such slow numbers when it comes
to racial donors you know historically
donors have been recruited from places
where maybe black men are not present
you know institutions of Higher Learning
certain areas Geographic areas in the
country listen to this it's also about
requirements most cryobanks need three
generations of medical family history
something not all black Americans have
access to the result many black women
across the country like Angelus depancic
eventually give up on finding black
donors altogether it was overwhelming
the drought was overwhelming stepancic
who describes herself as half black and
half Croatian welcomed a multi-racial
baby girl last year with her wife I'm
used to creating relationships and
ensuring that relationships are stable
despite what difference may be and so I
have no concern about raising my
daughter as a beautiful black woman in
America I wonder if there were
non-negotiables if being black was a
non-negotiable when you started the
process and at some point you realized
it is a concession you must make in
order to have a baby yes yeah it
absolutely was at the start we
I mean you imagine you always want your
child to look just like you right to to
be like you or Browner right for us and
so it was a little bit difficult but
frustration ultimately turned to
inspiration for us to panzik this year
she plans to open the first black owned
cryobank in the country what do you want
to give women and couples who are
looking for this warmth safety options
right I wanna I wanna give them access
to the same amount of options that every
other couple has going through this
process
reproductive Village which will focus on
recruiting black donors is set to open
in D.C this fall it will also have
drop-off locations in Houston and
Atlanta as for the big four cryobanks
they say that they're aware of this
problem and right now they're working to
recruit more diverse donors well this
never occurred to me that getting black
sperm in particular would be a problem I
love uh Jamila I think her name was who
said I wanted a baby that looked like me
when you said what were your
expectations do you have any statistics
on how this affects other races is it a
problem for other races as well well
according to our analysis the biggest
shortage as we discussed in our piece is
really black donors but this is not just
an issue for black Americans the numbers
of Hispanic and Asian donors those are
also very low but I do want to point out
in those categories they Encompass a
really wide range of different
ethnicities so for instance Asian
includes both East Asian and South Asian
donors so if you're a recipient in that
situation that's not all going to mean
the same thing and when you do this look
like we were blurring out faces like
when women are looking for their donor
they're seeing pictures so they're
getting some information like you just
gave us but then also headshots they're
seeing pictures and the more important
piece of that is the skin that that
person is so they're finding all of that
out but the problem is as you mentioned
Gail a lot of these women don't know
this is an issue until they start
searching yeah I'm sure these big four
are hearing this and saying wow we're
not serving these customers now we've
got competition opening up in DC we're
going to get on it well it's a great
business plan and I did reach out to you
know the big four cryobanks a lot of
them are saying they've known this is an
issue for a long time now the problem is
when these places opened years and years
ago the phenotype that many women were
looking for at the time was white tall
blonde blue eyes uh educated and the
people who are now looking for sperm is
changing and becoming more diverse what
we need now to see is diversity in
donors yeah last time I checked tall
dark and handsome is still a good thing
no complaints with that no no complaints
Angela opening up the black owned
cryobank I think yeah it's great it's a
big deal yeah Chanel call thank you for
being here Bravo good job welcome